now to our top story here at home today
is the first full day of closures on the
I-15 as project drop a can of continues
it's of course Saturday a prime time for
people to be out and about so how are
drivers coping with this Madison
Kimbrough is live near the desert in
overpass tonight with more in Madison
how's it looking out there
well Sasha like I mentioned earlier this
weekend would probably be better spent
at home it's 11 p.m and take a look as
there is still a traffic slowdown on
I-15 and those I spoke to share what a
hassle it's been
it's crazy like gotta take one exit more
and it's close till too long like I left
from Costco this morning I gotta go to
Henderson it took me like hour and a
half drivers across the valley having to
find alternate routes to get around ever
since project Tropicana began with one
of the biggest closures this weekend
I-15 closed in both directions between
Flamingo and Russell that area won't
reopen until Monday and even still Lanes
will then be reduced with all the kids
and activities and stuff like that it's
been getting in a way of a lot of it so
and you know and then trying to make
your employer understand if you are
going to be a few minutes late this
phase includes the destruction of the
Tropicana bridge over I-15 previously
the I-15 southbound off-ramps to
Tropicana Avenue had closed down and
currently Tropicana over I-15 is closed
set to open back up on Monday as well
student Katie Holman says she's
frustrated with the long drive to school
but knows the construction needs to get
done sometime it's really difficult for
me to get to my house to UNLV I'm
actually glad that the roads are getting
fixed though because it was really bumpy
on my way there
and even though I-15 will open back up
on Monday still expect delays as Lanes
will be reduced now the whole project is
meant to better our Highway for drivers
and pedestrians along with raising the
Tropicana Bridge reporting live Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now